a family get together as it were of
humanoid robots in the old they're in
their element at the robotics trade fair
in Oh Robo around 140 established
companies startups and research
institutes are showcasing how humanoid
robots are set to change the way we live
not the possibilities are the ultimate
interface between man and machine for
the time being there's a preserve of
research centers but it won't be long
before they become part of our
households there came a time when
everyone wanted a car and one day
everyone will want their own humanoid
robot it's a dream and one that Reem see
from Spain is making come true the
life-size robot can walk by itself and
carry up to 10 kilos right now it costs
of cool 300 thousand euros and is only
used for research purposes
then there's the joint European project
I cub a bit like a small child who can
grasp objects and will hopefully in
about five to ten years become a helpful
household companion
now from France meanwhile is 60
centimeters tall and one of the few
humanoid robots currently available on
the market for upwards of 5,000 euros
more than 6,000 nouns are already in
operation
that includes soccer players at the
RoboCup World Championship and in
schools where their job is to get kids
excited about science but manufacturers
like poo nomas aigner are well aware of
people's reservations about humanoid
robots gopal dobu when you talk to
people about the prospect of robots that
can help with children in the housework
and I mean the most people have their
doubts and say oh I'm not sure I want
one around the house look it's business
but then psychology kicks in when they
see one yeah for example when they see
now they love him and want to have him
lots of people relate to robots based on
what they've seen in movies do buckaroo
John Vitale thielemann
humans have long tinkered with notions
of the man machine they're a staple of
sci-fi genre be it in the form of
technology gone haywire
what am I as helpers in everyday life
or even as beings made in the human
image researchers at the technical
university in gashing near munich are
working on robots with artificial
intelligence this is their baby bro boy
he's 140 centimeters tall and comes the
closest yet to the ideal of a humanoid
robot instead of motors his joints
resemble muscles and tendons he can even
show emotion when will there finally be
a show called robot max for us the comic
book appearance plays an important role
with roboy we've redesigned him a few
times especially the head we had a vote
on Facebook and people could choose the
cutest hit that was crucial for us
because row boy is so skeletal and at
first he doesn't come across as friendly
but we want him to be a positive asset
ER for this kind of research that either
fell from the fossil level in the future
he's supposed to help people with
everyday tasks and perform services in
social institutions
busy of a boat ahoy it's certainly going
to be a few decades before we have
robots that could do all the work around
the house cooking ironing wash on and so
forth that's because it's extremely
difficult to interact with our chaotic
environment we don't understand the
necessary procedures well enough yet
Luca dived us asimo from Japan perhaps
the most prominent machine man yet made
shows how a robot can be integrated into
daily life he can push a tray trolley
climb stairs or serve breakfast in 15
years he could be a normal part of our
lives and his European colleagues aren't
far behind
robots won't have a significant role in
our everyday lives for some time to come
but who knows maybe soon we'll hire them
as reporters for robot max goodbye see
you soon